Ce n'est même pas
qu'ils ont fui le pays,
c'est qu'ils ont fui le pays
et ça ne sert à rien qu'ils y retournent
parce qu'ils n'ont plus rien là-bas.
Et donc, tu te dis :
qu'est-ce qu'il leur reste en fait ?
Salut à tous,
c’est Cyrus North
et je suis actuellement
au Liban,
plus précisément à l'est,
à la frontière avec la Syrie
qui se trouve
derrière ces montagnes.
Je suis venu avec le média Brut
pour vous parler des conditions
de vie des réfugiés syriens dans le pays
et pour vous partager
leurs témoignages.
Le Liban est un pays du Proche-Orient
qui compte approximativement
4,5 millions d'habitants.
À cela, il faut ajouter 1,5 million
de réfugiés syriens
qui, depuis 2011, fuient la guerre
dans leur pays.
Au Liban, c'est donc 1 personne
sur 4 qui est réfugiée.
Salam alaykoum.
Donc là, on est dans une tente
assez classique
des camps de réfugiés syriens au Liban.
C'est Yasmine qui nous a gentiment
invités chez elle.
Choukran.
C'est une tente qui est assez spacieuse
par rapport aux autres tentes,
il y a une famille nombreuse
qui vit ici.
Ça reste très rudimentaire,
il n'y a que 2 pièces,
il y a celle-là dans laquelle
il y a toute la vie qui se fait
et il y a une chambre, il n'y a pas de cuisine
comme vous pouvez le constater.
La cuisine est à l'extérieur.
On est sur des matériaux
très rudimentaires aussi,
on a quelques planches de bois
et sinon, on a juste de la toile en fait,
une toile de l'ONU.
Contre des vraies intempéries, il n'y a...
pas grand-chose qui résiste ici.
L'hiver, ça veut dire qu'il fait froid
aussi parce que c'est mal isolé.
Demain, s'il y a des pluies torrentielles
qui viennent, voilà,
on est à même le sol,
forcément, ca va être inondé.
Il y a beaucoup de familles syriennes
au Liban qui vivent dans ce type de logements.
Ce sont des conditions de vie
extrêmement difficiles,
notamment pour des enfants.
Pour bien comprendre l'exode
des Syriens au Liban,
il faut remonter jusqu'en 2011.
Ça fait alors 10 ans que Bachar Al-Assad
est au pouvoir,
la situation dans le pays, notamment
d'un point de vue économique
et en matière de libertés publiques,
ne s'est pas améliorée.
À ce moment-là, plus de la moitié de la
population syrienne a moins de 25 ans
et un tiers des jeunes sont au chômage
malgré le niveau d'éducation
assez élevé dans le pays.
En écho au Printemps arabe,
la population manifeste alors,
pour demander plus de démocratie
et plus de droits
mais la répression du régime
est extrêmement violente.
Arrestations, emprisonnements, tortures,
tirs à balles réelles sur les manifestants.
Le pays sombre peu à peu dans le chaos
et la guerre civile.
Depuis le début de la guerre,
il y aurait eu plus de
510 000 morts en Syrie
et selon le Haut Commissariat
des Nations Unies pour les réfugiés,
les combats incessants
ont fait 6,6 millions de déplacés dans le pays
et 5,6 millions
dans le monde.
Apparemment, il y a des enfants qui ont préparé
des petits jouets à nous montrer.
Donc on va voir ça tout de suite.
Salam alaykoum.
Alors dites-moi,
vous faites quoi ici exactement ?
Qu'est-ce que
vous fabriquez ?
On fait des voitures.
On a vu comment
elles étaient faites
et on les a reproduites
mais différemment.
On en fabrique des comme celle-là
ou des ventilateurs.
- Montre-nous le ventilateur.
- Je l’ai mis en marche.
On les soude l’une sur l’autre,
on lui branche
des fils électriques et ce moteur.
Et l’électricité est ici.
- Comment tu soudes le plastique ?
- Avec de la colle,
nous avons de la colle.
J’aime créer des objets parce que
j’ai plein de choses pour.
Mais parfois, je n’ai pas
tous les outils pour créer.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler
de la vie d'une adolescente
dans un camp de réfugiés syriens
comme celui de Saadnayel ?
Nous sommes
comme dans une prison,
ni plus ni moins.
Nous ne pouvons pas
quitter le camp seuls,
nous ne pouvons pas sortir
après le coucher du soleil.
Toutes ces choses
nous sont interdites.
J’ai quelques libertés
et ma mère ne me met pas
trop la pression.
Je suis soit à la maison
soit chez ma tante
qui est aussi dans le camp.
- Et tu veux faire quoi plus tard ?
- Je rêve d’ouvrir une boutique
de coiffure et d’esthétique
et de partir à l’étranger.
Ça, c’est mon grand rêve,
de partir et me construire
un avenir ailleurs avec ma famille.
Je partirai de cette prison.
- Choukran.
J'espère que tes rêves
vont se réaliser,
que tu vas sortir du camp
et que tu vas trouver un job
dans le make-up, maquillage, coiffure.
C'est vraiment tout ce que
je te souhaite.
La source de l'ensemble
des problèmes des réfugiés syriens au Liban,
c'est sans doute l'absence
de papiers légaux.
On considère, par exemple, qu'il y a 75 %
des Syriens qui sont présents au Liban
qui ne disposent pas de
permis de résidence légal.
Ça veut dire que ce sont des personnes,
des familles, des parents, des enfants
qui ne vont pas vouloir se déplacer
par crainte de se faire contrôler,
par crainte de se faire, ensuite,
arrêter parce qu'ils n'ont pas
cette documentation légale.
On parle avec eux depuis hier,
aujourd'hui et ils te racontent
leurs rêves,
toutes leurs aspirations, etc.
Il y en a un qui voulait devenir pilote,
il y a une fille
qui voulait travailler
dans le maquillage...
Il y a en qui font des dossiers
pour partir au Canada, en Italie,
dans les pays européens.
Mais je comprends
cette envie de partir d'ici.
Comme vous avez pu le voir,
les réfugiés syriens
vivent dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles
et ils ont parfois vécu de vrais
traumatismes.
Là, on est à Beyrouth,
la capitale du Liban,
on va dans l'hôpital public
le plus grand du pays,
pour rencontrer d'autre réfugiés syriens
qui bénéficient d'une aide
en santé mentale.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me raconter
un petit peu votre histoire
et ce qui fait
que vous êtes ici aujourd'hui ?
Je suis arrivée
au début de la guerre.
Je suis venue ici en 2011,
en septembre.
J’étais enceinte
au 9ème mois d’Ahmad
et j'avais déjà Hassan et Hala.
Les tirs avaient commencé,
les balles sont passées
au-dessus de la tête de mes enfants.
J’avais peur pour
la vie de mes enfants
et c’est pour cela que
je suis venue.
On croyait que la situation
allait se calmer au bout d’un an ou deux
et qu’on rentrerait chez nous
mais ce n'est pas possible.
La situation
ne s’est toujours pas calmée,
ma maison a été bombardée...
ma mère est décédée...
Mon frère aussi est décédé.
Ma mère et mon frère
sont décédés
sans que je puisse les voir...
La situation est atroce,
on n'a plus de pays,
plus de maison.
Même ici, il n'y a pas d'espoir.
Je suis fatiguée et nous sommes
dans un état psychologique instable.
La guerre m’a poussée à venir ici
pour protéger mes enfants.
Nous n’avons ni pays,
ni endroit pour vivre, pas de vie...
Je me demande parfois
pourquoi nous subissons tout cela.
Il y a maintenant 8 ans,
ils ont perdu leur maison.
En fait, ce n'est même pas
qu'ils ont fui le pays,
c'est qu'ils ont fui le pays
et ça ne sert à rien qu'ils y retournent
parce qu'ils n'ont plus rien là-bas.
Et donc, tu te dis :
qu'est-ce qu'il leur reste en fait ?
Et ça, quand elle te le raconte
avec ses enfants à côté qui jouent,
qui se marrent.
Et entre deux larmes,
t'as un sourire pour ses enfants.
C'est hyper fort,
c'est hyper triste.
Le fait de mettre
des visages dessus,
d'avoir quelqu'un face à toi
qui te raconte ça...
Enfin, sa vie...
Elle a vécu des choses
extrêmement difficiles.
Il y a une dimension empathique
et il y aussi une autre dimension
qui est que le déni n'est plus posssible.
C'est-à-dire que quand
la personne te raconte son histoire,
ce n'est pas au JT de France 2,
entre deux je ne sais pas quoi,
enfin tu vois...
juste avant
un match de foot, quoi.
Non, c'est...
C'est l'histoire
d'un semblable.
Ici, on est dans un centre
de santé mentale,
comment on vous aide
ici, concrètement ?
Je ne savais pas que
les thérapies psychologiques existaient.
Quand mon fils a été hospitalisé
ici, à l’hôpital Hariri
où il a été opéré des reins,
j’étais au plus bas.
J’ai expliqué ma situation
à la dame qui m’a reçue.
Ma fille souffre de beaucoup
de problèmes de santé
physiques et psychologiques.
Elle a vu ses troubles
s’améliorer de 75 %.
Elle s'est très bien rétablie.
Je les remercie beaucoup
et je conseille à toute personne
qui souffre psychologiquement
de se faire soigner.
Il ne faut pas en avoir honte.
Les thérapies psychologiques
ne sont pas pour les fous.
Bien au contraire,
je me sens beaucoup mieux
ainsi que les enfants.
Merci beaucoup.
Le fait de me raconter
tout ça, c'est...
C'est hyper courageux,
c'est hyper fort.
Donc il y a ça qui m'impressionne.
Et ce qui m'impressionne aussi,
c'est...
cette force où elle est capable
de t'expliquer comment
elle a perdu sa mère,
comment elle a fui son chez soi
pour sauver ses enfants et tout...
Et en même temps,
il y a ses 4 gamins à côté,
il y a sa petite fille de 11 mois
qui court partout,
elle est là, elle la chope,
elle les calme.
Waouh !
Quelle maîtrise !
Quelle force !
C'est admirable.
On se rend compte que
les problèmes psychologiques
sont extrêmement graves,
on en parle très peu.
Alors que potentiellement,
ça concerne
des dizaines de milliers de réfugiés
qui ont vécu des traumatismes.
On considère que ça risque
d'être un problème explosif
dans les années,
voire dans les générations à venir,
car c'est une génération entière
d'enfants, de jeunes adultes
et évidemment d'adultes aussi
qui sont marqués par
non seulement par
les traumatismes liés à la guerre
qu'ils ont pu vivre.
Un enfant, même
s'il est aujourd'hui au Liban
depuis 5-6 ans, s'il a quitté
la Syrie à l'âge de 3-4 ans,
ça veut dire qu'il a forcément
entendu des choses,
qu'il a forcément
vu des choses
et qu'il a vécu, intégré,
digéré des situations de stress
qui ont été vécues par ses parents,
par son entourage, par sa communauté.
Les séquelles morales
et psychologiques
sont extrêmement violentes
et même, ça continue.
C'est-à-dire que là,
ils sont sortis de Syrie.
Elle racontait que, en gros,
il y avait une discrimination
et que ses enfants subissaient
la discrimination
dans le quartier, à l'école, etc.
C'est hyper important
que ces enfants-là soient suivis
et que ce ne soit pas,
elle le disait elle-même,
que ce ne soit pas un tabou,
que ce ne soit pas un problème
de venir discuter de ça
avec des spécialistes.
Et un jour, justement,
si la Syrie arrive à se reconstruire...
Il est important qu'effectivement
les générations de Syriens
qui vont revenir, qui vont naître,
soient protégées
dans ces problématiques
de santé mentale
quand elles existent ou quand
elles sont prêtes à se déclarer.